all
right make a video here let's just put
this right here put you set you
up hi how's it
going
so uh I actually woke up like
this got to find some stuff in here I
just wanted to say happy vlogmas today
is December 1st it's the first day of
vlogmas which is Vlog every day until
Christmas I'm trying to a little more
presentable the problem with making
YouTube videos sometimes is I don't feel
like taking a shower I don't feel like
putting on makeup I don't feel like
changing the clothes that I'm currently
wearing that I slept in which cracks me
up about reality shows because they are
about as real as something that's not
real at all this is the realest of the
freaking real that's why I love the
Internet it's awesome I can make a video
here talking to you sitting in my room a
little messy as usual and that's what I
want vlogmas to be it's going to be
pretty freaking real you're going to get
videos every day until Christmas maybe a
few days after Christmas there's a
really good chance that in most of these
videos I may or may not
shower I also didn't 100% wake up like
this because I put pants on I also put
on a bra and I also went to Whole Foods
to get a coffee so it's sort of like I
kind of sort of woke up like this I'm
also working on an i gift guide on what
to give your friends and family for the
holidays basically it's going to be one
big list of just some cool things that I
like because it kind of drives me nuts
sometimes when they segregate the girls
gift guide the guys gift guide because
my mom showed me what the little boy's
gift guide was it was video games Legos
and Minecraft or something and she's
like just see look this is you I'm under
the boys category so I think it's really
hard to categorize people
because little girls can like Legos too
little girls can like video games little
boys can want to wear princess dresses
and it's okay you can do whatever you
want Oh The Croc go wild I forgot where
I was going with this oh the gift guide
I'm wondering what do you guys want for
the holidays like what is it that is on
your top to want list so we're still
going to do some tech Tuesdays here for
vlogmas we're still going to do some
cooking videos for vlogmas and in
between all of the normal videos that I
would normally be doing will be Vlogs of
things that I'm doing that I would
normally post anyway I'm just going to
try not to skip a
day I don't know this it's funny
because I've been wearing the shirt for
weeks I took a picture and I posted it
into my family group and Brienne was
like you have not taken that shirt off
since you bought it and she's right I
haven't I wore it all last week when I
was home and now that I packed my
suitcase back up to come back to Los
Angeles I dug through my suitcase to
find this stupid shirt and it's so great
it was on sale which made it even more
awesome anyway I just wanted to give you
a nice
warm welcome to vlogmas and explain
what's going on here my floor is
cracking and it sounds like it's my
ankles so if you hear that throughout
this video I don't even know if this is
working I haven't used this camera in a
while and it's a little dirty also make
sure you guys don't forget that I do
have a gaming channel so I'll be playing
video games over there right now I'm
playing Far Cry 4
I love this game so much it's so much
fun I can't wait to finish it so that I
can move on to the next game I'm not
letting myself play another game until
I'm done with that one so I think that's
all that I have to say here today hey
hey you can is this
focusing are you focusing am I even in
focus focus great I love this camera I
bought this one a long time ago and it's
still my freaking favorite okay I'm done
we're done here we're done here I'm
actually going to go shower because I am
not
clean just be glad that you're on the
internet so yeah welcome to vlogmas it's
real it's freaking real also let me know
if there's any t-shirts that you guys
would like me to make because I need to
make some new ones so yeah I think I
left you guys some homework
um yeah I'll see you later shower
time welcome to vlogmas
pigs